[Musique]
y a personne qui peut vous prouver
demain matin que les ogm en tant que
telle la modification génétique pose un
problème de santé pour la pour la
population parce qu'il n'ya pas d'étude
donc c'est sûr que si on ne cherche pas
on ne trouve pas trois commandes avant
cela il existe des centaines d'études
d'impact au niveau environnement adapté
sur la santé également n'auront eu
toutes ces données le plus long
maintenant de 25 ans d'expérience
d'applications la l'amélioration
génétique par sélection et par
croisements se fait depuis des milliers
d'années
françois belzile et professeur en
génétique des plantes à l'université
laval
alors il ya des choses font qu'on
pourrait pas faire par hybridation
simplement parce qu' il existe poste
caractéristiques l'eau au sein du de
l'espèce qui nous intéresse et l'on vaut
donc chercher à l'extérieur
pour compléter le tout ces modifications
génétiques conduisant à l'obtention
d'espèces transgénique les fameux ogm
là on parle de gm on pense aux
laboratoires mais la transgénèse il y en
a plein à la date on l'a pas inventé en
fêtant on la copie
on utilise des outils des bactéries pour
nous aider à le faire pour ne trouver
dans nature
dominique michaud du centre de recherche
et d'innovation sur les végétaux de
l'université laval est un pionnier dans
le domaine
donc on cherche toujours à améliorer nos
plans nous animons que c'est la même
chose pour les protéger donc développé
de la résistance à une maladie tibouren
coordonnateur de vigilance ogm demande
un étiquetage obligatoire
on demande depuis longtemps de la
transparence dans nos assiettes donc le
fait de savoir s'il existe ou pas des
organismes modifiés dans nos épiceries
donc dans nos assiettes
[Musique]
mais où sont donc ces fameuses ogm au
québec par exemple plus de 50 pour cent
de toutes les cultures de toutes les
terres agricoles au québec s'est désolé
m avec du maïs et du soya destiné
principalement à l'alimentation des
animaux
ils sont aussi présents dans certains
produits transformés qui contiennent des
dérivés du canola soya ou du maïs les
étapes de transformation font que à la
fin soit qu'on n'a filtré éliminer ou
dégradées le matériel en question mais à
la fin quand on dit ça le nouveau gène
dont introduit on est détectée plus
pratiquement on ne retrouve pas encore
dauger m dans les fruits et légumes que
l'on mange
mais les choses pourraient changer avec
entre autres l'apparition d'une pomme
transgénique vendu précoupés la pomme
arctique ne s'oxyde pas et garde sa
couleur originale pendant 28 jours on
n'ajoute pas de nouvelles protéines de
l'extérieur on ajoute de l'information
génétique pourrait les empêcher
l'expression d'une protéine qui est déjà
dans la pomme puis qui la cause du bruit
des semaines lorsque on va couper
lorsque des blessés pour l'instant cette
pomme est uniquement produit aux états
unis
l'entreprise s'emploie à développer de
son côté une pomme de terre qui résiste
aux meurtrissures lors de la récolte
avait des combats de gaspillage ça peut
être intéressant
c'est peut-être mon gas témoins
nourriture de plus cette pomme de terre
produit - d'acrylamide pendant la
cuisson une substance potentiellement
cancérigène
malgré tout l'industrie de la pomme de
terre au canada n'est pas chaude à
l'idée de mettre en marché une pomme de
terre transgénique
mccain s'est quand même 40 % de toutes
les produits surgelés à base de pommes
de terre dans le monde donc c'est un
gros joueur eux ils ne veulent pas donc
est-ce que ça va bloquer cette
production encore cette fois-ci en 2021
on l'espère il y a aussi le cas du
saumon transgénique d'aquabounty à qui
on a introduit un gène d'anguille et une
hormone de croissance d'un autre ce
moment pour qu'ils grossissent deux fois
plus vite d arriver sur le marché en
2017 et 2018 au canada c'était 4 5
tonnes ce qui représente un infime
pourcentage à ce jour l'entreprise a
toujours refusé de révéler où s'y
retrouver la chair de ces saumons en
fait ce saumon là par contre en fait ce
qui s'en vient c'est que on a la
première production industrielle
mondiale qui va sortir de l' usine de
l'indiana ci a été approuvé c'est que
les données ont démontré qu'ils avaient
pas de problème n'était pas plus
dangereux qu'un surnom entre angers nec
qu'on achète tout moment vous consommez
que ce soit l'alimentation humaine
directe a même une plante ogm ou
indirecte via des animaux qui auraient
consommé des aliments dérivés des ogm
je connais aucun corps où on ait pu
indiquer qu'ils avaient eu un effet
néfaste une conséquence néfaste associés
à ce phénomène
vigilance ogm soutient que les études
sur la santé sont insuffisantes
c'est impossible d'identifier
actuellement de faire des études
épidémiologiques pour dire quelqu'un qui
mange des ogm quelqu'un comment je pense
qu'il ya une différence statistique sur
la prévalence de maladies parce qu'on
sait pas où ils sont donc déjà on pourra
jamais vous donner la réponse
les niveaux de risque associés aux ogm
n'est pas supérieur au niveau de risque
liés pause 0 il n'est pas supérieur à ce
qu'on rencontre dans l'agriculture
conventionnelle
ça c'est les conclusions auxquelles
arrivent les recherches scientifiques
maintenant est ce que ça veut dire qu'il
aura jamais de problème il faut toujours
être vigilant
une des sources d'inquiétude les plus
documentés et la relation entre les ogm
et l'utilisation des pesticides comme le
controversé glyphosate au canada 100 %
de tous les ogm sont faits pour tolérer
un herbicide et qui augmente à moyen et
long terme l'utilisation des pesticides
là on sait très bien qu'il ya des études
solide
des fois la technologie se s'avère
tellement un triangle pour des
producteurs que l'appât du gain est de
vouloir encore une fois le maximiser à
court terme les profits au fait en sorte
que on oublie certaines bonnes pratiques
agronomiques de varier les cultures de
faire la rotation des cultures des
moyens de lutte
les sondages effectués montrent que 80 %
des canadiens et 85 % des québécois
souhaitent un étiquetage obligatoire des
produits contenant des ogm
le jour où on l'étiquette pour du beurre
mais il ya ça tout de suite ça suscite
une certaine interrogation puis quand il
ya des gens devant l'épicerie qui ont
leurs pancartes qui disent aux gens vous
allez pousser un troisième bras bon ça
fait ce que ça fait là et donc ça c'est
sûr que c'est pas tout à fait très
attractif pour un quelqu'un de mettre
une pareille étiquette au canada si un
ingrédient dans un produit représente un
risque pour la santé comme par exemple
la présence d'allergènes on doit
l'indiqué si on trouve pas de mention
sur les ogm c'est que le gouvernement
canadien les considère comme sécuritaire
et les questionnements les inquiétudes
sont souvent les mêmes mais peut-être
parce que ça pas été répondu de façon
satisfaisante depuis vingt et un ans
ben en fait c'est un droit fondamental
de savoir ce qu'on mange